foreign
let's move on to some social media
questions here we've got one from
Facebook Rudy has a question for us can
you ever have valuable clutter
it's like a trick question yeah one
man's clutter is another man's Fortune
right and so
I
your clutter
that is cluttered to you may be valuable
to someone else but by definition
clutter that gets in the way for you is
not valuable to you because if you were
getting value from it you would not feel
compelled to
cling on to it cling to it without using
it right and so no clutter by itself is
not valuable even if that item is
valuable in the marketplace if Ryan gave
me a Lamborghini today
and he said you can't do anything with
this but continue to own it it would not
be valuable to me at all because I
wouldn't use it I have no desire to
drive a Lamborghini personally with
someone else if I could sell it they may
say oh yeah I'd be happy to give you two
hundred thousand dollars what a steal
for me yeah and so it could be valuable
for them even if it's not valuable for
me so I don't like making the grand
sweeping statements where this thing is
junk and no one should own it obviously
not it's just not appropriate for me I
think I'd give you 200 Grand before I
gave you a Lamborghini
because I know you so well
oh man I'll hold my breath yeah so I I
actually
um I don't know like some people they
collect things I'm trying to think like
my brother-in-law there's a game called
like um Warhammer and it's like these
little Miniatures and he paints them and
they look really really good and I can
look at those and I can appreciate like
oh wow like this collection that you
have this is pretty cool like I could
see where you find Value in that but
yeah to me it would be it would be
absolute clutter
um so yeah I mean there are people out
there with Collections and they really
enjoy their their collection of whatever
it is and we're not here to judge and
say that no that could never be valuable
it's really about like how how valuable
is it to you because certainly any pile
of clutter any horde is gonna have some
value the question is is do you value it
more than the space that it would create
if you let it go oh yeah that's great
yeah so projection is when we take our
own thoughts and feelings and we
externalize them as coming from other
people introjection is when we take
other people's thoughts and feelings and
we internalize them as if they are
coming from ourselves it's very easy to
both project and and traject with
clutter so for instance if I see someone
else who has an object that I don't need
that stresses me out I project by saying
oh that's clutter but it might be
creating value for that person and they
might enjoy it or if I have things and I
know there's someone else out there who
has fewer things I get a little insecure
and say well they might think it's
clutter and so I interject and then I
feel guilty about the things that are
creating value in my life it's important
to step back and say clutter for me may
not be the same as clutter for you it's
determined by usefulness it's determined
by the value that it brings to me the
other thing I would say is there's a
distinction between actual and
hypothetical value that's important for
questions like this actual value is
something thing that plays an integral
role in the plans that I have now
whereas hypothetical value is this is
something that could be valuable if my
life was something other than what it
actually is it's just in case disguised
in the language of value right and so
sometimes when we think about things in
terms of like can you have valuable
clutter it's like well all clutter is
hypothetically valuable
but the question is is it actually
valuable do you need it right now or is
it a burden to your life right now and
you're just hanging on to it because
you're telling yourself a story that one
day for reasons you can't anticipate
your life might change and then you'll
regret having let go of this thing don't
let hypothetical value get in the way of
your ability to enjoy the actual value
that is in the here and now that sounds
like a we could make another minimalist
rule with is it uh yeah is it is it
actual value or is it hypothetical value
yeah that's that's a great approach I
was listening to Bobby Brown before the
show so Josh was like think that's where
you're getting your maximums from I was
like yeah 80s 90s r b there's always
something John B is going to sue us any
moment now
I got one more rule for you I was gonna
do this during the talk aboutable
segment but since we have a second I
call it the let go anyway rule
let go of something you want to keep
if it makes room for something
meaningful
something more meaningful than the thing
you would hold on to I call this the let
it go anyway like oh yeah I get some
sort of value from this the hypothetical
value or maybe I just get a little bit
of value from it but maybe you'd get
more value from letting it go we call
that the let go anyway rule I love it
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free